hey i'm malik pancholi and i play budgie
on phineas and ferb
hi i'm d bradley baker the voice of
perry the platypus
hey i'm alison stoner and i play
isabella garcia shapiro hi i'm vincent
martella
and i play phineas flynn on phineas and
ferb
[Music]
here we go how would your bffs describe
you
smart loyal creative charming
trustworthy or ambitious i'm going out
on a limb here i'm gonna pick charming
just because i want my friends to think
that i'm very charming
i'm gonna choose creative i think
because i i come up with weird ideas all
all day long it feels awfully
pretentious but i feel most
comfortable saying smart because my
nickname growing up was dictionary queen
and i love learning i am i think i think
i'll go with
i think i'll also go with creative for
me if you were a cartoon character what
would your signature look
include flower crown bright blue hair
comfy sweatshirt
leggings combo floral sundress plain
white tee or a leather jacket
i'm going with plain white tee i'm a
comfy sweatshirt
leggings combo yeah i i went with bright
blue hair because i just had bright blue
hair now it's kind of green
i got to go with floral sundress it's
still summer
i just can't let go of that choose a
character you trust
with a secret perry the platypus buford
stacy carl vanessa
or jeremy perry i'm going perry the
platypus
yeah he can't tell anybody all he's
going to go is
that's all he's going to say so you
don't even know what that is choose an
iconic celebrity to appear on
take two with phineas and ferb dwayne
the rock johnson
reese witherspoon harry styles britney
spears
danny devito or cardi b britney spears
i'm going danny devito i i would love to
interview danny devito
as phineas i don't know any of these
people so i'm just choosing danny devito
because he's bald and
i relate to that i'll go for the other
balds man
dwayne the rock johnson he seems fun
choose an invention you'd like to create
sunglasses that transport you into any
tv show
a phone that lets you communicate across
dimensions
cookies that give you super powers pants
that dance for you
cars that drive themselves or gum that
tastes like your favorite meal
cookies i want to invent cookies
sunglasses that transport you into any
tv show what tv show are you going into
any tv show
i'm gonna go with a phone that lets you
communicate across dimensions
no i'm going cookies that give you super
powers because i want super powers
finally choose something important from
phineas and ferb isabella
dr coconut love handle the flying car of
the future
today the fireside girls aglets
or the first innater i'm going with
aglets
i'm gonna have to go with love handle
because it has an umlaut
i'm also going with aglets that's that's
extremely important information that
we gave to a generation i'm gonna join d
love handle for the win
[Music]
dr doof wears comfy sweaters and
leggings
he has peter the panda slippers in one
episode he has the little peter the
panda slippers
this brings me back to realizing that
maybe i am pretentious because doctor do
i'm gonna go back and take this quiz as
many times as i can until until you get
what you want yeah
your personality matches phineas you're
innovative
friendly and super creative like phineas
you hate boredom so you're constantly
thinking of fun new ways to spend your
time
people just wish they could be as cool
as you i mean that's a pretty good one
i got candice your personality matches
candace apparently
i'm ambitious bold charismatic i also
love to have fun
now that i'm done reading that i'm fine
to be candice
and to have my own movie i got dr duven
schmertz
you're intelligent impulsive and a
natural born leader
like doofenshmirtz you have a really
creative mind
that all of your friends are a little
bit jealous of
deep down you have a heart of gold is
this time for an identity crisis or
should i say that for later
i'm questioning so much mine made sense
to me i feel very comfortable
i think these results are perfect
[Music]
you